et salut à tous ses amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mme encore et
aujourd'hui je vous montre une petite
astuce super simple pour rendre vos
vidéos encore plus stylé aujourd'hui on
va parler de mouvements de caméra sans
bouger sa caméra
ouais ouais alors le mouvement question
ça s'appelle un travelling et l'idée
c'est que ce soit un déplacement super
fluide quand on est pro on peut utiliser
ce qu'on appelle un slider qui est une
espèce de raï qui va permettre
d'effectuer ce mouvement de façon super
fluide mais ça coûte la peau des ou
alors on peut utiliser un stabilisateur
mais ça aussi ça coûte la peau des mais
rassurez vous même quand on est seul et
quand on n'a pas de matos on va pouvoir
utiliser une petite technique qui va
nous donner un effet quasiment similaire
alors est d'accord c'est là pas être un
vrai travelling mais ça va nous
permettre de dynamiser un plan fixe qui
peut être relativement chiant et comme
d'hab c'est fait sur final cut mais ça
marche nickel avec première ou avec dai
ichi
tout ce qui va nous falloir c'est un
plan fixe filmé sur un trépied et quand
on aura terminé on aura un léger
mouvement qui va nous donner un petit
peu plus de dynamisme
alors pour illustrer ce tuto on va
utiliser un court métrage que j'ai
réalisé sur la chaîne si vous ne l'avez
pas encore vu tout les cliquez ici vous
pouvez cliquer là je sais jamais où nice
mais le truc mais vous pouvez cliquer
pour voir cette vidéo est jeune homme de
suite comment on fait alors ici vous
pouvez voir que j'ai mon plan fixe qui
est pas particulièrement intéressant il
est ça va être d'en faire un travail
donc je vais sélectionner mon run je
vais appuyer sur les touches contrôle v
et ici je vais afficher l'animation
vidéo je me caler au début du run et je
vais cliquez sur l'outil transformé je
vais ensuite aller cliquer ici sur ce
petit plus qui va me permettre de
déposer une qui freinent que vous pouvez
voir ici là vous voyez là qui freinent
sa fiche
si vous ne savez pas ce que c'est qu'une
qui freinent vous pouvez cliquer sur le
lien qui s'affiche sur votre écran donc
j'ai ma première qui freinent ici est ce
que je vais faire un peu je vais réduire
ici un petit peu pour bien y voir c'est
que je vais à grandir ici mon image et
je vais venir la déposer ici la décaler
plutôt sur le côté
jusque là une compliqué ensuite je vais
aller à la fin de mon run ici
et je mets cliquez à nouveau ici pour
rajouter une image clé que je peux
déplacer ici image par image pour
modifier mouvement maintenant que j'ai
ma qui freinent ici je vais tout
simplement déplacé mon image ici en
restant bien sur le plan horizontal et
ce qui va se passer c'est que l'image va
se déplacer au fil de la timeline
voilà donc ce n'est pas ou feint on est
bien d'accord c'est pas un travelling de
deux mètres de long
mais sur un plan fixe qui va être
relativement bateau ça va rajouter un
petit peu de mouvement et c'est la somme
des détails qui va rendre la vidéo plus
ou moins stylé alors on n'est pas non
plus obligé de le faire que du
travelling latéral on peut faire du
travelling vers l'avant ou vers
l'arrière et pour ça je vais utiliser ce
plan ici je vais re appuyé sur contrôle
vais placer maquis frame ici voilà voyez
là je vais ensuite aller à la fin du run
est en place et une deuxième est ici en
fait l'idée ça va être d'avoir un zoom
donc tout simplement je vais à grandir
mon image
au fur et à mesure là pas trop quand
même
et voilà hop on a un travelling avant et
là je vais pas vous montrer mais vous
pouvez aussi faire un déplacement de
haut en bas en diagonale bref vous allez
pouvoir réaliser un mouvement de caméra
un petit mouvement de caméra en post
production
si vous n'avez pas la possibilité
d'avoir quelqu'un qui vous film par
exemple ou si vous vous rendez compte
que vous avez un plan fixe qui
finalement n'est pas si dynamique que ça
pour me donner un petit coup de peps
alors mon conseil par contre c'est si
c'est possible de filmer en 4k puisque
comme on va agrandir on va zoom et donc
on va perdre définition donc voilà si
vous êtes en cas de cas il ya aucun
souci vous exportez votre projet en 1080
hd et il y aura aucune perte de
définition par contre si vous êtes comme
moi pour le coup uniquement hd ça marche
quand même vous pouvez le faire il n'y a
pas de souci mais il faudra juste pas
vraiment trop parce que sinon vraiment
on aura une perte en définition là comme
vous avez pu le voir dans le tuto moi
j'y suis allé mollo
donc voilà si vous êtes là quatre cas
c'est cool si vous avez que du 1080
doucement sur le zoom et jamy c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui c'était une astuce
super simple super basique mais qui peut
un petit peu vous sauver certains plans
si elle vous a plu d'ailleurs n'hésitez
pas à exploser
le petit pouce bleus qui se trouve en
dessous de la vidéo ça fait toujours
plaisir et ça soutient la chaîne tout
comme le fait de vous abonner si vous ne
l'êtes pas encore ça fait bien plaisir
c'est cool et voilà je me kiffe les amis
surtout rester curieux et moi je vous
dis à très bientôt pour une prochaine
minés
[Musique]